hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk about
terminator Dark Fae Jimmy Cammy
returning to produce and work on the
story for this Tim Mille directing it
we're just gonna do a spoiler talk for
you guys and we're just gonna talk about
this as if you've already seen it we're
not gonna go through too much to
reiterate anything before we go into
that though I want to thank everyone who
has downloaded and followed us on that
Stardust app thing I'm a jiggy over
there thirty second reaction reviews for
films TV shows and or trailers post and
daily over there and then it's usually
the best place to go to if you want to
get our opinion at first before we've
got a youtube video we cover things on
there that we don't even cover on
YouTube plenty of YouTube influencer
personalities and people who didn't make
it into film but are making it on the
internet over there to any home quick
thoughts you know before we hop into
full-on spoilers overall I would say
that I give this a three-and-a-half
stars
it's probably where I'm gonna rank it at
now there's a lot of caveats here I
think Linda Hamilton is excellent in the
film literally when she starts speaking
you're like yeah she's such a necessary
addition to this franchise and Mackenzie
Davis is pretty damn good in the movie
italia Reyes is alright Luna is good
with what he's got given Arnold
Schwarzenegger surprisingly funny in
here not really into that much but when
he's there he really does shine and
there's a lot of really fun action in
here as well I really did enjoy it and I
think is like an action movie it's
really cool as it compares to the movies
that followed Terminator 2 it's
definitely better than those movies like
by a lot I think that being said as a
true Terminator 3 movie there are things
about it that I flat-out hate that
occurred pretty early on weirdly it's
one of those experiences even though I
didn't really feel much when I was
watching this movie there's there's a
lot of big spoiler things to actually
talk about that are definitely not
addressed in the trailer and even though
a lot of these spoilers there's like one
major spoiler in the beginning in this
movie the rest that are big spoilers are
predictable yet they're pretty heavy
spoilers so yeah that's my overall
thoughts I feel like as the movies still
ended Terminator 2 but as far as like
a fun action escapism or some weird
fanfiction because you could call this
Terminator
references if you wanted to because
every single zine is loaded with the
references and nods and sometimes it
just borders on straight-up copying as
opposed to Oh moshing hey my opinion
yeah yeah I mean I feel like every
Terminator since Terminator 2 has done a
fair amount of that weirdly I got way
more distracted by that in Genesis but
I'm kind of with you on everything you
just said I mean I'm sort of at a three
and a half star range I think there is a
lot to appreciate I think yeah as an
action rollercoaster right it is pretty
capable in a lot of respects but as the
true Terminator 3 oh it is not and it's
gonna make you really upset if you try
and look at it that way I think if you
if you really love those first two
Terminator films for everything that
they are and not just for the Terminator
action I think this is a falling short
of the mark it's weird to be like you
really don't want to compare it to
terminator 1 & 2 but at the same time
this movies asking they even invited
every step of the way hey sing wise
build-up wise that's where they really
should have taken the most notes because
this movie kind of swings into it all
because when this movie started it
starts off with this footage of
Terminator 2 that the freakout moment
videotape and t2 freeze frames not hurt
and I thought it was cool to see that
footage again it was more than just
nostalgia I thought it was a good way to
reintroduce us back into Sarah Connor
maybe they're gonna go for a little bit
more of this kind of tone perhaps a
psychological anguish of all this yeah
and then they go on to the beach like
okay there's some familiar Terminator
stuff I thought was a little distracting
that they had CGI terminators but with
the old sound effects you might as well
commit to a brand new thing and then
they're doing this moment where it's
like a couple years later or something
there's this beautiful de-aging that
they do on Linda Hamilton like I think
everyone was like wow it looks so real
it looks like it could it be a deleted
scene they even see young Edward Furlong
did this is when they started to just do
[ __ ] that I just did not agree with
they're saying that okay apparently they
sent back like multiple terminators to
kill John Connor Skynet did okay I
thought this was a for some reason I
thought I was watching a dream like
another
like Sarah Connor dreaming yeah I
thought this was another dream Young
Arnold shows up nyeh late and weirdly
young Arnold is the one that they
couldn't get right good
like that looks strange young Arnold
shows up annihilates John Connor and I
still thought I was just watching a
dream I still thought this was just some
weird vision they were gonna cut away
then eventually we'd check in on older
Edward Furlong in the film or something
and then a few minutes went by and I
realized wait they just like killed off
John Connor like he was nothing this was
the 80s and it was part three yeah like
some people might flash to like Newt in
alien 3 Kate in Nightmare on Elm Street
4 or freaking Johnny Cage Mortal Kombat
annihilation like you just like you
people we love right away the thing
though is is like if you look at John
Connor his mantle is significantly
higher than even those supporting
characters in those movies it's John
Connor to call this the true Terminator
3 was kind of a spit in the face for
that moment
Edward Furlong John Connor is not my
favorite performer or favorite character
but he's such an essential piece I mean
Terminator 1 is about protecting the
mother who will give birth to the
Saviour number two is protecting the
savior I'm not in the camp that's
completely opposed to killing off John
Connor and then having this be a setup
for Linda Hamilton Sarah Connor
character I think the way it was handled
was incredibly poor and so early on with
the voice-over and then you're seeing
all this like technology woody aging
there's so much distracting and it's
moving so fast
it's just thrown out there as some like
expositional narratives set up as if he
was nothing and I hated that
and I also hate the concept of they sent
back multiple terminators ok if you're
gonna throw all this in there why didn't
you just do that to begin with from the
80s and when she was pregnant and stuff
like it just it makes you question all
these different rules and then on top of
that it's just a spit in the face I
really did not care for the way they
handled the setup at least yeah I mean
this movie has that flavor to me
throughout where there are a lot of
ideas I think are good there and I feel
like I've said this about every
terminator because it's probably true
and I think this one gets it more than
perhaps a lot of the other sequels had a
lot of good ideas that I think are
worthy that could have worked
could have been an interesting follow-up
to what Terminator 1 and to set up but
yeah it's the execution and the handling
of those things I hate to do it but I
couldn't help but think of Martin
Scorsese throughout this whole movie
these blockbuster films being theme
parks and not delivery systems for an
emotional experience the thing is yeah
Terminator has always been a sci-fi
action franchise partially at the very
least but if you look at terminator 1 an
especially Terminator 2 a lot of
emotional delivery that goes with that
stuff and the problem is this movie has
so many ideas that could have
interesting emotional ramifications and
it never bothers to live very long with
anybody like I think they did a good job
capturing that paranoid were on the road
were on the run sort of vibe of the
first couple Terminator films they never
add any finesse to the plot they never
allow for an ebb and flow of tension
they're never quiet moments to be
interrupted so everything is so frantic
that you're just kind of watching a
conveyor belt of ideas go by mixed in
with set pieces
yeah they lead into everything
especially when it's so obvious that
what they did was take elements from t1
elements from t2 Mackenzie Davis is a
hybrid of Arnold from t2 meets you know
Sarah Connor and then Natalia Reyes is a
little bit of spliced of that too
Gabriel Luna is Robert Patrick you know
like all these different riffs are
happening and then the setup of Natalia
Reyes the Mexico setting I thought was
cool and I thought Natalia Reyes was
actually fine in the first half I don't
think she's that great in the movie at
the same time I don't really think it's
her fault I don't because he helps her
at all there's a there's a plenty of
scenes where she actually does a good
job but then there are scenes where
she's really not good but the whole
scene is not good like it's everything
in that scene is not good so I think
it's easy to focus on her and be like
they gave her these big inspirational
moments but they just ring as incredibly
corny and cheesy and just and totally
uneffective because of that backtracking
at the beginning of this movie like they
swung into the adventure really fast
yeah it's like they breeze past all the
things that make t1 and t2 work so well
which is the build-up to getting on to
the adventure the build-up to Kyle Reese
finding Sarah Connor in the showdown and
going on the run the build-up to the
mall where Arnold fine because t2
a riff on t1 in the first half yeah and
so like you could do a riff on it but
still have the build up be proper and in
here they're kind of just zipping
through it till I races cool Mackenzie
Davis I think is excellent in this role
honestly like there she was the best
part of the movie to me she was the most
engaged in the most compelling thing on
screen I suppose for me it was Linda
Hamilton
I thought Linda Hamilton kill I honestly
you know I've never really found Linda
Hamilton attractive but there was
something in this movie it's as old as
she is now and as apparently old as she
is now I don't know why there's
something that's pretty hot about her
pretty sexy about her I mean was
terrific hers moments are some of the
best parts of this movie I do think
though that some of her role is good
because of her and not because the
writing whereas I feel like with what
Mackenzie Davis was given to work with
and the amount of commitment she put
into her role because she's in such a
tough position as a character she really
was the emotional core of the movie yeah
me where's Sarah Connor is still kind of
a supporting character everyone feels
like a supporting character and somehow
I feel like it should have been
Mackenzie Davis's movie it felt like
overall it was her movie more than
anyone else's yeah it yeah I mean she
gets the big triumphant moment and in
the end to the first 45 minutes of this
even moving like I didn't sit there
ruminating on what annoyed me about that
John Connor thing I was like all right
I've had to forgive a bunch of other
Terminator shitty sequels to get on
board with the adventure so I could
enjoy the movie I was able to do it 43 I
was able to do that for Genesis even
like I didn't walk out hating those
movies I was like they aren't good but
III was able to at least enjoy it
knowing it's not good here it's more of
a mixed bags or things that are
genuinely good here here's how I would
describe it the first half of this movie
I enjoyed a lot more than the last half
but the last half of this movie has
Arnold Schwarzenegger in it and I enjoy
Arnold a lot here the dynamic between
Arnold and Sarah Connor I thought was
great as well I connected with her
emotion and there are things that they
set up that are supposed to be these
twists that are so freakin predictable
that are in the trailer like twist one
is with Arnold being who's sending Linda
Hamilton these messages for John yeah
do it and scene for 45 minutes who might
know who John is well the thing with
with Arnold's t800 like yeah that's so
predictable that that's gonna be him
when they officially confirmed that and
when they get to the farm in Texas that
the Arnold's living at I had a thought
of I wish I saw that movie I wish I saw
the low-budget Sarah Connor like you
could have done like John Connors killed
this Terminator from some alternate
timeline that has now been wiped out
because Skynet's gone
yeah well man we even talked about the
whole Legion thing yeah it's kinda that
Skynet is gone it could be a movie
focusing of Linda Hamilton all these
years trying to hunt down the t800 it
could be like Kill Bill Vol to who you
know at the end where she found like oh
damn he's like him that's the Hamiltons
daughter but you know he has a family
now if you cared a conflict it could be
as a character study of her where she's
evolving into the human Terminator
yes evolving into the Terminator human
it could be almost Devil's Rejects see
in a compelling kind of way what made
the t800 in this work was Arnold
specifically because it's Arnold and he
is funny like him talking about the
drapes was hilarious just him saying and
I'm extremely funny it was a funny [ __ ]
hilarious and that's the best comedy in
the movie is when it's being sort of
character driven comedy and there's also
meta comedy that does not work here
absolutely there's a little nugget that
I appreciated where he's petting a dog
and they established in Terminator 1
that they used dogs to sniff out the
terminators if dogs are always barking
it's like when Gabriel Luna shows up at
the door the dogs barking it's a
terminator thing not once does the movie
call attention to that and go dogs not
barking and I wish the movie did more of
those things like the movie could have
benefited a lot from more subtle
undertones subtle nods to pick up on
things for fans invest for a movie
that's riffing so much on t1 and t2 I
thought they could have done a better
job at just acknowledging that the
people who are watching this are fans of
t1 and t2 and instead of having to over
explain a lot of things go on and
instead of throwing in very lurid nods
like oh is he gonna put on sunglasses
that he wouldn't even know about yeah
now okay
you know like it's cute but at the same
time yeah when you're trying to go now
this is the third Terminator we did a
Q&A on patreon about the difference
between a movie and a film yeah and
honestly this is a great example of that
for me because I feel like it had film
ideas on its mind but it's in a total
movie package well the whole thing with
Arnold learning to be human actually
goes against a lot of Terminator
especially the explanation of it I'm
actually not opposed to the concept of a
terminator learning to be human it's
been I thought the reasoning was dumb I
thought the reasoning does not work
somebody like I like Tim Miller I do I
think somebody else should have at least
been on the script for I mean they have
so many writing and story credits for
this but I feel like somebody else
should have written this because there
are a lot of great little concepts that
Teeter on the edge of this could be
super stupid or with the right
explanation it could be actually pretty
cool because they say you know once you
know he carries out his mission he has
no more mission and now there's also no
more Skynet so he's kind of stranded in
time and that's interesting to think
about because now that literally the
circumstances of his existence have
changed he can adapt and and yeah but
you're only given a couple lines for any
of those kinds of ideas that float
through this movie you don't really get
to explore any of those concepts so it's
up to you to go I like this idea I'll
take it or not the explanation for it
was like kills John Connor and then and
then let Sarah Connor live and then
saves abused woman and then starts it's
none of them made sense with what a
terminator is to have gone down that
path they could have followed a lot more
along the lines of the t2
special-edition where the the whole
thing with the CPU and changing it out
of his cranium something like lived in
that a little bit yeah I just I thought
the explanation overall was is not
satisfying goes against goes against
Terminator 2 lore to me especially for
gonna be the real t3 yeah it just goes
against it and the whole thing with
Legion so stupid I think they they
sacrifice John Connor they wiped out
Scotty to me the Legion just and it was
all the expense so they could set up a
new franchise that's pretty much what it
was to me they didn't focus on a
Terminator 3 they focused on setting up
a new franchise and it's very evident in
everything here the whole idea of Legion
is the
as thing because it's 100% Skynet it's
the same thing as Genesis without phones
it's Skynet it's all sorts it yeah it's
like let's okay no more Skynet but then
this legion thing starts they build
exactly technology the same technology
the same time travel the same strategy
the same strategy to wipe out the future
leader the same models they all look
like terminators they all seem to have
the same conceptual art why not just
make it Skynet you could have just
expanded upon this why not go far enough
to make Legion something special instead
of literally just a name you mentioned
and it doesn't matter at all yeah like
it's a MacGuffin and yeah that this
movie is full of that kind of stuff
though and that's a bummer when it comes
around to the characters especially
because Natalia Reyes like the the Dany
character is also you know the
recontextualization of oh she's not
Sarah Connor though she's not got the
baby who's gonna save the future it's
her it's her hope she's going to inspire
the resistance and the movie makes the
gravest mistake by putting her in the
background of every scenes they have
other characters ago she is going
through a whole lot with this thing she
didn't ask to be saddled with but you
never get to know her at all though you
took that and it's blah it's bogged down
by plot and it's by a like too much plot
and being a rollercoaster like there's
some set pieces here that don't need to
be as long and indulgent as they are and
they work against the movie when you
start tuning out of the action yeah the
finale especially like the finale got
way too big for my taste when they're
flying off of a plane that crashes into
the dam and therefore there were
shooting and are in the underwater and
they're firing guns under water in the
Hummer
you got a no you got is Sarah Connor
who's an established old drunk I'm just
like there's no way she would die like
she's like I killed terminators and I
drink till I blackout and I'm like you
can't live that way and be good at what
you do I do have to be a hard-ass of
some kind like sure I'm sure you drink
or whatever but like there's no again
flesh to justify the line so you're
basically left to go I accept it or I
don't I guess yeah one thing that I felt
would subtle undertones going back was
Natalia Reyes especially with that whole
West that wasn't like dumb is dumb to me
especially the way it's handles this is
weird because this is turning to a 20
minute complained about Terminator gar
fakers a lot of things complain about
because it shows you what's not working
in a really clear way but like I have to
remind you guys that in between a lot of
this it's not fun cuz it's bad like
there are some genuinely fun things when
this movie should have been doing action
it's cool good action and then when they
take the time to have good seat like I
feel like the genuine good scenes are in
the first half of this movie the last
half there's a couple of moments with
Arnold that are all right I don't care
for the flash-forwards or that or their
flashbacks for things that boy the
McKenzie Davis's character the first one
was cool when it's kind of like an edge
of tomorrow meets aliens kind of where
you explain how she got augmented one of
those is alright the whole thing with
like little girl
Talia Reyes which aesthetically was was
bad because they they didn't even bother
to make her look older like she was
younger to me you put her hair tied up
there's nothing that earns her this
leadership thing gotta say you know like
Terminator 1 you watch Sarah Connor
evolved from timid scared waitress into
a total badass by the end like she earns
that final moment in this movie I'm just
supposed to buy that she's gonna evolve
into this person well yeah then when you
do the flash-forward what I want to say
is like that flash-forward like that
would have been more effective you could
have had the same plot thing where
Mackenzie Davis John Connor Kyle Reese
thing is with a riff and on Mackenzie
Davis she could have just explained that
and you could have just felt the history
there but when you show it it's just
corny about the way about this that I
did about its chapter two in a lot of
senses where I was like these are cool
ideas please play most of them in the
present with the characters were talking
to right now because if they had had
that as maybe and I mean we complain
about info dumps but if they had had
that as a scene between them like on the
train top or something where Mackenzie
Davis is like look you're not ready for
this but I need to tell you about who
you become that could have been an
interesting character moment for our
characters in the president instead of
having this action sequence
flash-forward that lets you get
distracted by the fact that yeah she
looks it's younger than she does in the
presidents because the fear of the
future should be
ominous when Kyle Reese is explaining
the whole
like goes on the monologue before he
sleeps with Sarah Connor imagine if
instead of playing it in the present
they show he's doing a voiceover
narrating over scene or in Terminator 2
the countless times they talk about the
future they that they have to know when
to show stuff when just play it in the
present and too much of this is like we
don't need vo for everything man
honestly John Connors death off screen
might have been more effective if you
didn't actually if he showed it later or
he just let the scene go with no
narration over it let Sarah tell the
story and watch the emotion exactly tell
this or that of just like quickly going
cool effects bro yeah Oh 30 seconds
later he's dead Bo Bo ain't over there's
no emotional impact to it like the sad
thing about this movie to me is that I
can really feel the market testing in a
way I really hoped I wouldn't because of
all the faith the James carriage ride do
instill in us and the thing is you
naturally the Friday the first half of
this movie showed me what physically
isn't working about terminator now and
the second half showed me what
somatically isn't because the thing I
also realized is that we also I think
loved the first two terminators because
of the constraints they existed within
you watched the first part of this movie
and I started to realize that to me
anyway that not everybody might share
this opinion but there is this overall
synthetic quality that most all post
Terminator 2 films have terminator why
is that just doesn't read the same way
whereas in the original two films they
use their CGI very wisely because they
had to and the rest was done pretty well
and yeah and that grounds everything
where is this movie when you have the
script working against you in the fact
that it doesn't care about the emotional
experience of the characters very much
and you have the heightened effects
everywhere and the overabundance of
action sequences to you know character
moments ratio it all starts to feel like
again a big theme park ride that isn't
convincing to me the way Terminator 2
was because it felt so tangible and I
bought the stakes and it felt like time
mattered and space mattered and there
was danger I don't get why Mackenzie
Davis is Grace just did not the whole
thing was trying to pull like we got the
audience
she's not just Sarah Connor she's John
Connor hey that was wildly predictable B
I'm like well what's
why do when they're on the train when
they're on top of the Train oh it's
because you're gonna be the mother
you're gonna mother the that's it at the
moment the whole thing with like her
that people complain about with films
being more woken feminists agendas and
blah blah blah
this was the only time I felt that like
one who and she's like it's people that
you're supposed to carry the man who
will save us or whatever line Sarah
Connor says then they do this really
corny ass moment with no you thought
your son you they practically could have
said you're a woman that's fine I don't
care that Natalia Reyes is the savior I
don't care that she's a resistance
leader that could have worked but why
does it have to be some reveal they
could have just put it on that scene in
the train and have her deal with that as
her emotional journey instead of plot
twist ha ha and even her an emotional
journey to help us believe that at all
exactly so she could evolve into a
fighter just telling us every 20 minutes
on man you've been through some [ __ ]
that mostly we watched Linda Hamilton
and Mackenzie Davis deal with yeah our
gender flip in this it was that was the
only time like I was on board for three
women on the road the whole time I
rarely agree with people when they have
when they get mad at like half the time
people say woke I don't even like feel
like that's the case they just read into
it like that well this was the only plot
thing that I felt that way this movie
arguably was woke her than a lot of
action movies beforehand anyway but the
soul having Sarah Connor be who she was
back in Terminator 2 so yeah to have it
take a step back in terms of its themes
there is kind of a drag the biggest
betrayal to me honestly is that moment
where they were teaching her how to
shoot because I feel like in a previous
Terminator movie we would have had to
not watch her learn to shoot yeah
physically instead of having Sarah
Connor just whisper in ear someone just
killed your whole family and now you're
great at shooting you're perfect it's no
wonder John Connor died this is how you
train yeah and so and that just really
showed me what this film had on its mind
which seems to be you have more
franchising more action they want the
continuation of Terminator more than
they want to make a great way of doing
that like there was more finesse put
into like a lead of battle angel than
terminator yeah to me it's not a
surprise that this movie
a fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes is all
right like I keep saying this alien
covenant I still enjoyed it like I
enjoyed it but from a terminator stand
through the hype of this is must to be
the real t3 i think this movie's been
getting a major pass because it's better
than the ones that came after t2 but
let's say though like but let's say we
those did not exist and this was the
only sequel after t2 we would hate like
that's plain and simply like what
happens this would be like it's one but
no that's like Oh clearly James camera
didn't make this movie like after what
they did with like I mean the Christian
Bale's John Connor sucked Nick stopped
all his John Connors barely memorable
what they did with Jason Clarke as John
Connor is like by the time you get to
killing off John Connor here it annoyed
me in the sense of this is a direct III
but I think I was able to move past it
because I'm like John Connor has been
sucky for like three movies that's why I
think I was able to move past it pretty
quick but in the media moment that was
very annoying
bottom line yeah it's weird because you
know the thing is we're gonna do a
spoiler talk these are the things we
feel passionate about there's plenty of
great action and there's plenty of great
performances this script the
storytelling dealing with Terminator
lore I thought Gabriel Luna elevated a
lot harking back more Robert Patrick was
a cool idea weirdly I got to the point
though you know who ante to Robert
Patrick just keeps coming back and it's
scary and menacing and I hate submitter
just like how do you defeat this guy we
have no idea what we're gonna do with
this movie it was the superhero
equivalent of just keep punching him to
the certain point because i weirdly
didn't feel too much threat even though
it was threatening and I thought Gabriel
Luna was good and I love whenever he had
dialogue I thought he was awesome with
the dialogue for some reason I was like
they're gonna handle it I mean I thought
they did a nice job of harkening back to
the slasher movie vibes that t1 has with
him in his moments but the other thing
I've realized in talking about this is
that most of the Patel
scenes in all yeah or it tries to be but
it's not prolonged enough to actually
stick that tone because tension requires
breath the plot maneuver and idea is
there but tonally it's not this is a
yeah this is a hyper non-stop
rollercoaster action movie that
occasionally drags in parts and it has
moments way more than it ever has seen
yeah that's that's the biggest issues
like he's great and he could have been
Robert Patrick level menacing if there
had just been some scenes rather than
just cool or eerie moments you know a
line or two you know
Gabriel Lunas Terminator hates
windshields every single time he is
behind the wheel of something his first
instinct is to break that would you know
because Robert Patrick did it it's gonna
like quadruple down just like Dewey Cox
in the band the sinks it's just like any
windshield he sees let's bless that
thing that's it that's what he's doing
in the scenes he's not on screen he's
just walking through town busting
everyone property damage Terminator dark
fate you guys see it did you like it do
you have the same complaints do you like
his movies a flop anyway you guys can't
ask subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification Bell check us out in
the Stardust app catch you guys soon